PAUL IRISH: Hi, and welcome
to The Breakpoint.
This time, I'm joined
by John McCutchan.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey, everyone.
PAUL IRISH: And we're going to
talk about remote debugging
and getting a lot more insight
as far as what's going on on
your mobile device.
There's a lot of tools inside
of Chrome DevTools to deal
with this and specifically
identify the pain points that
you're having with performance
that you encounter on mobile.
We're going to show a few
cool things today.
We're going to show seeing the
things that are unique to
mobile inside the DevTools
Timeline.
We're going to cover
about:tracing and extracting
one of those traces from the
phone, show off things like
Continuous Paint, and
talk about why all
this matters so much.
Sound good?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
that sounds great.
PAUL IRISH: All right, so first
up, we're going to dive
into an app by the
"New York Times"
called the Times Skimmer.
And we're going to take a look
at the timeline of it.
So I have this up here
on my phone.
And meanwhile, I'm also
in Chrome DevTools.
So I've already set this up
to do remote debugging.
We'll show that in
a little bit.
But I'm going to come over here
to the timeline and start
a new recording.
And now that I've got that
going, I'm just going to
navigate to the new section
on my phone.
So Times Skimmer is just going
to navigate over to--
there he goes.
And that's going to come in.
So I got a few things
going on.
That's why the phone is
a little sleepy here.
But we're going to end
the recording.
You can hit Command-E as
a little shortcut.
And we can dive in to what's
going on here.
So it looks like quite a bit.
One of the things we see--
this, actually, right here, so
this is a Rasterize call.
And the reason why it's an
empty, hollow bar is because
it happens off the
main thread.
There's a lot of things on
Chrome on Android that do not
happen inside the UI thread.
Whereas on desktop, currently
some of them do.
And this hollow bar indicates
that that is happening
off-thread, which means that
this click event handler where
we go into jQuery and we start
doing things, this can all be
happening in parallel because
this is operating on a
separate thread.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Nice.
PAUL IRISH: We go down here.
We see all these paint and paint
and paint and paint and
paint and paint and paint.
All of them, they're very small,
and they're not taking
up a lot of time.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: How long
are they taking?
PAUL IRISH: Let's see.
So we've got about a
millisecond each.
That adds up.
So we're targeting 16.6
milliseconds for 60 FPS, so at
almost a millisecond
each, this is--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's going
to take a while.
PAUL IRISH: It's going to
absorb quite a bit.
So this is going to be
a little chunky.
But sometimes it's hard to
identify what's going on here.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to turn on another mode
that we have.
So I'm going over
to the Settings.
I'm using the question mark--
it's a little shortcut--
to get into Shortcuts.
I go over to General.
I'm going to turn on Show pane
rectangles and composited
layer borders.
Now, I come back.
And on the phone, what we're
going to see is anything that
gets painted is going to be
rendered in a red rectangle.
Anything that is composited
as a layer onto the
GPU has gold borders.
And so this time, I'll try
recording in Timeline again.
And we're going to navigate
once more.
And now you see a few things.
You see that there was just a
moment where there were gold
borders around all the icons on
the side of the navigation.
And then there was
a blink of red--
red paints again.
And the content is on its way.
But now when we take a look
at what's going on in our
Timeline, these small little
42 by 45 paints make a lot
more sense.
Even if I hover over them, we
see on the phone, a little
blue area indicating the
dimensions of where that is.
So right now, it's showing up
in the top left corner.
And in about a week from now,
that'll be showing up right on
the space where that
paint was done.
But you're getting a good idea
of the dimensions of that
paint and seeing where
it came from.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So that means
I'll be able to, from within
Timeline, hover over a paint
and see the visible
region on the phone?
PAUL IRISH: Exactly.
Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's
awesome.
PAUL IRISH: So not just the
duration of it, but we have a
map of the location on where it
happened and the dimensions
of the paint itself.
And like I mentioned, there's a
small bug in location right
now, but that's on
its way out.
So this is pretty cool.
So I'm getting a sense of not
only the full performance
view, not just what's happening
in JavaScript, but
all my paint costs as well,
and it can identify
what's going on.
And so this is a good example
here where it looks like we're
parsing a bunch of HTML.
It's taking a while.
We're still parsing HTML.
I think some JSON has come back
from this XHR, and we're
now sending it through a
templating engine and piping
it into the DOM.
And it looks like this indicator
is telling us that
we have a forced synchronous
layout as a possible
performance bottleneck.
And why is it forced?
It's happening inside here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So is
this the call stack?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, so this is the
call stack of what led up
to the layout being forced.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And so this is
where the layout was forced in
the bottom left.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: OK, great.
PAUL IRISH: So I can click in
here and identify that--
so, inside app source, it's
this guy right here.
This.offsetHeight is a known
property that forces layout.
The browser has figure out the
new geometry of the page.
And so I know where
this is happening.
And then if I want to get a good
idea of why we needed to
even call that, we can watch
this call stack and see that
we were in mark, notify.
We were getting JSON
back here.
But we needed to do some work
in order to figure this out.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's
really cool.
To be able to see on the
Timeline that there's a really
expensive layout operation going
on and then just jump
right to the call stack, that
gets you right to the source
of the problem.
PAUL IRISH: Right.
And so then the next thing best
to do at this point is to
eradicate this.
Basically, anytime you see this
little indicator, we want
to get rid of it.
And so in this case, if we can
avoid hitting offset top at
this point-- maybe we can ask
for offset top earlier in the
application, cache that, and
then just apply that value
inside here so that we don't
have to go ask the DOM, hey,
what's the news story in the
geometry of the page?
That would mean that we don't
have this big jump between
these operations, and then it
would be a lot more snappy.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's cool.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, so that's a
very quick summary of the
power of the DevTools Timeline
on mobile and getting a good
sense of what's actually
happening.
There's things that I didn't
show as far as image decodes
and image resizes.
If you've seen these times on
desktop, you can expect them
to take, on mobile, around 6 to
10 times the duration that
you're used to on desktop.
So all those costs are much more
expensive on the mobile.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So that means is
if your site is running in,
say, maybe 10 milliseconds per
update frame on desktop, then
you could expect 100
milliseconds, maybe?
PAUL IRISH: Pretty much.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's
a big difference.
PAUL IRISH: It hurts.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the most
exciting thing for me about
DevTools on mobile is that
it's the exact same as
DevTools on desktop.
So everything that you learn in
using the tools on desktop
is applicable on
mobile as well.
It looks like we just lost
our connection, but we'll
reestablish that.
PAUL IRISH: We should
have that back.
There we go.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There we go.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
So we'll take out these
settings for now.
Yeah.
So do you want to show a little
bit more about:tracing?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
So for those of you aren't
familiar with about:tracing,
this is a real low-level staring
at the guts of what
Chrome is doing when it's
rendering your site.
And so the way you access this
on the desktop is you navigate
to about:tracing.
And you can start a capture,
and it captures it.
But since this is a mobile, it's
a little bit different.
And I've been maintaining
a Python script
that activates it.
And so let me just
run it right now.
And when I do this, Paul, could
you just navigate a
little bit on the device?
PAUL IRISH: Sure.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: OK,
are we ready?
PAUL IRISH: Ready.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So there's a
little balloon pop up, and
Paul's going to navigate,
maybe scroll around.
How are we doing?
PAUL IRISH: There we go.
We've got both things, scrolling
and navigating, so
we're good.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right, so
we're going to press Enter
there, and the balloon will pop
up on the mobile device
saying that the capture is
complete and that it's going
to copy it over to
the desktop.
So I'll just load
up chrome.json.
Wow, 16 megs-- a lot
of data in there.
This is pretty low level.
Oh, now this is starting
to look interesting.
So we have some animations
here, stacked
on top of each other.
PAUL IRISH: Are these keyframe
CSS animation?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There's comps
that are animation.
So let's see here.
We'll zoom in.
So there's the VSync tick, so
this is kicking off the draw.
And now, here you can see that
we're preparing to draw.
We're doing the layout.
Everything is being updated.
When you really need to get this
low-level, nothing beats
Chrome://tracing.
And it works just like it does
on the desktop once you've
captured the data.
PAUL IRISH: And actually, you
have a whole other GDL session
on this tool, what
you can learn.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I did a
GDL on Make the Web Faster in
December of last year,
so check it out.
I go into a lot of detail on the
value of this tool and how
you can use it to actually
instrument your JavaScript
code on top of just
instrumenting the
internals of Chrome.
I highly recommend it.
PAUL IRISH: It's good.
You look at this interface,
and it's
pretty daunting at first.
And there's a fantastic amount
of information there.
And once you get used to reading
it, you can extract
some really useful
insights in it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
To give you an idea, we spent
about an hour and a half
discussing Chrome://tracing in
this Make the Web Faster GDL,
and we're still just scratching
the surface.
So this is a tool for experts,
but you need it to truly
understand what's happening.
PAUL IRISH: And one last thing
we'll show you is that there's
a new feature that we're working
on that we want to
show off that's called
continuous
page repainting mode.
And so we're going to come
back to the DevTools, and
we're looking at one of the
pages inside Times Skimmer.
So we're going to turn on
continuous page repainting.
So what this does is it
basically says, browser, just
continue to paint, again
and again and again.
I know that you've painted it
once, but paint it over
because I am going
to do some work.
I'm going to play around
a little bit.
So once we turn it on, we have
the little feedback on how
long our paints are taking
on the phone.
And then we can go inside of
the DOM and start to play
around a little bit.
So in this case, I'm
going to go in--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So, hold on.
Before you do that, why don't
we talk about the graph,
actually, that is partially
visible in the upper
right-hand corner of
the mobile device?
So when mobile painting is
turned on, you get a min and a
max paint time and the previous
frame's paint time
and then a graph of
all of this data.
So it's really interesting
to see.
And the workflow here is you can
toggle on and off elements
and toggle on and off styles,
and you can try and determine
the cost of painting a specific
element with its
style, which Paul's going to
demonstrate right now.
PAUL IRISH: First thing, I'm
just going to bring us back to
the page we were looking at.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Cool.
There we go.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
So now that we're back here,
one thing that we can
experiment with in continuous
page repainting is taking
things off.
So there's a H shortcut.
Now, you can use it all
the time if you just
want to hide something.
So just hit H, and it will
hide that DOM node.
And so in page repainting mode,
what we're looking for
is what effect not painting that
element at all has on the
time to repaint.
So if it has a big, significant
drop, then we know
that this element and its
children are currently
contributing quite a bit to
the cost of painting.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
that's exactly it.
You're playing the
subtraction game.
If I turn this element off or
disable a style on it, the
time goes from being 100
milliseconds to 90
milliseconds.
So you can conclude that
that element cost 10.
PAUL IRISH: And then once we
find out the elements that are
costly, we can start working
through our styles in here in
the DevTools, toggle them on
and off, and identify what
parts of things are
contributing.
And sometimes just images will
be contributing, like a large
image will have a pretty
significant paint cost.
Other times, you'll be finding
box shadow and border radius,
and maybe some other CSS styles
will be contributing.
But here, you'll finally get an
idea as far as if you are
seeing large paint times in your
Timeline, we can identify
what exactly is really
contributing to those.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, just like
we were able to find the
call stack for the expensive
forced layout, you're
searching in that same sense for
the needle in the haystack
of why is paint so expensive?
And you can determine that just
by subtracting the paint
time for each element.
And you'll find one element
or a few elements that are
particularly expensive.
PAUL IRISH: Right.
I think the last thing we should
add here is why this is
all important.
One of the big things that comes
up again and again when
it comes to performance and
mobile is that a lot of times,
the mobile web experience isn't
as fast as it could be.
So this is really critical
to understanding, why?
What is going on?
It might not just be your
JavaScript is taking slow.
It might be things like paint.
But you really want to get
an idea of what are your
bottlenecks, so you
can adjust them.
The speed of scrolling is
something that we didn't
really touch on too much.
But you can also test this
inside the DevTools by going
into settings and trying
out the FPS meter.
So this is similar to continuous
page repainting.
It gives you a little meter on
what the frames per second is,
and I can scroll the page
and identify how
well things are doing.
Maybe something on the page
is really affecting
my scrolling speed.
But knowing that your page can
scroll fast means a huge
difference to your users when
they're using your site or
application.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: What was the
quote from Facebook where they
went down from 60 frames per
second to 30 frames per second
and saw a significant
drop in their users?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So having a less fidelity
scrolling experience really
hurts the engagement that
people-- like Facebook, who
ran an experiment and
got data on this--
have been seeing.
So targeting your scrolling
performance and your start-up
performance on mobile is really
key to holding on to
your user's attention
and engagement.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
and you hit on a
really important point.
It's very important when
doing performance
work to measure first.
You always want to measure and
determine, oh, it wasn't the
scripts that were slow.
It was actually this image
decode or a certain paint.
Once you have that data, you can
take the right action to
make the biggest impact.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Lastly, we started this up
really fast, so we didn't show
off exactly how we got remote
debugging started.
If you just look up remote
debugging in Chrome DevTools,
this is a recently released
article all about
how to get set up.
Right now, so you'll have to
grab the Android SDK, and
you're going to use a little
tool called ADB that connects
your phone to your machine
over USB and sets
up that data transfer.
But the instructions
are all here.
It's pretty straightforward
to get started there.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, the
instructions are on
developers.google.com, and I
have an article on HTML5
Rocks, which also goes over
continuous paint mode on
mobile and getting your
device connected.
PAUL IRISH: Is that out?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's coming
out next Tuesday.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So by the
time you watch this--
PAUL IRISH: So check out
html5rocks.com, covering
pretty much all the stuff
that we just talked
about in this episode--
how to get set up and how to
identify and improve the
performance on your mobile web
applications and mobile websites.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Cool.
Thanks very much for
watching, guys.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thanks.
PAUL IRISH: Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]